how is everyone doing today I'm good
before we get started the only reason
Collider gets to be here is because of
house of Aurora and I want to give them
a huge shout out for letting us be here
and letting us be able to you know
promote your movie so I I have to start
with first of all congrats on the movie
I had a congrats on the movie I have to
jump in right from the beginning with
the opening tracking shot because it is
I don't want to curse on camera but it
is frakkin awesome so I want to be
polite how did you pull this shot off
and what was the motivation of wanting
to start the movie off with like this
eight-minute shot the the reason why we
started to do the film with this long
shot was because we needed to get a lot
of information in that that explained
what was happening with all the
characters that tried to bring the
audience up to speed with with the
events of the past and try to kind of
chime in with the siege of a castle so
it felt to me like a really good idea to
try and combine that all in the one shot
just to kind of throw the audience into
the world and it fell like the ambition
of trying to get all this information
all this drama in Plus as a swordfight
plus there's a big trebuchet thing but
felt like that there was something
really interesting about doing that
without that the the the cut so
therefore the audience have to kind of
absorb it all in in the one thing so
that was the idea and then making it was
quite hard because there's a lot of lot
of moving parts and the guy we took at
least the first day we took trying to
rehearse it we shot it in four sections
and we thought okay so we got it we got
the backup if we were in trouble you
know and then the second day we I think
we did it more and then there was a
storm or something that prevented us
from doing anything else so we were
given a second a third day and so we'd
refined it Jake my editor had cut some
of the stuff that didn't feel quite
necessary out of it I think it started
off as a 13 minutes shot and then you
know by the time we defined it it's
AIT's eight minutes it just got tighter
and tighter and tighter and everyone
just got into the groove of it and we
eventually kind of found that the take
that we really like we should pretty
much the last time we shot but we were
saved by the storm
because it allowed us to just have a
little extra time to refine it otherwise
we would have been you know putting out
a cut a slightly less interesting
version of it when what you first heard
when you when he first tells you you're
gonna do this and try to pull this off
does this immediately excite you do you
get nervous and when you're in the
middle of the shot are you sort of like
freaking out a little bit because you
don't want to be the one who blows it in
front of all these people
yeah I thought he was just being a being
a I was pissed off for sure we'd already
shot a [ __ ] day and then it was
storming and raining and there's mud and
we were in these pop-up tents are
basically falling over because of the
rain and the mud then he was just
rehearse the corner of this thing while
they were so yeah we were all pissed but
as David said once we got into the
groove of it I think I was like doing a
play it's like doing it it's like being
in a giant stage play and there are a
lot of moving parts and in the
choreography of where the camera is when
someone's in frame when are they moving
out of frame when can you leave frame to
go to your next spot I'd completely dug
it I mean I was terrified a little bit
during the sword fight that me and Billy
would screw up somehow but as David
always likes to say you know when you
can find a happy accident you know you
obviously in those things are you want
perfection you're never gonna achieve
perfection but in that in that dance you
find some new stuff I thought it was
great it's beautiful yeah I mean it's
it's it's it's that beautiful dance like
you said and a noun and it feels very
much like theater and
and my character actually enters halfway
through that shot so when you're saying
about you know which do you feel like
you might be that one person to fudge it
all up I definitely had a bit of that
anxiety going through my mind and went
to like I said when you got to enter
this shot but it did it became something
we perfected I mean I hats off to our
incredible stammers our a Steadicam
operator because that like David said
the first time we did it was a thirteen
and a half minute scene no now to carry
that kind of equipment and then go right
now everyone back to ones and we'll go
again you know was quite an astonishing
thing to do and and we all became and
because of that it became very intimate
and we were supportive of one another in
in their elements I mean and then again
like you said to see that fight sequence
to see the first thing you see the first
fight sequence you see and a bookend to
this to this movie between Billy and
Chris is extraordinary that you guys
pulled that off whilst doing a monologue
I mean and that sort of artistry and
that's what the genius of McKenzie
brings to to a film like this it's it's
it's visceral and it's and it's fast
paced moving and and and it's artistic I
mean it's everything you want to see in
the first opening shot of this movie I
mean I think it was in many ways
serendipitous that the storm came
because it forced us to we couldn't
shoot and so obviously Jake talked about
the length of the scene and we sort of
edited it a little bit and cut it down
we talked about it with Steve and Elaine
and everybody cresent billion and then M
you know we rehearsed and rehearsed it
and then when it came to it we'd only
did what like two takes but I mean I
think his boys were seen it was quick
theatrical and its nature but I mean you
were aware of the camera you were aware
of stuff you know he's moving around but
at the same time you were unaware of it
you know because you were just of in the
moment and there was always something to
watch you and if you weren't seeing
something I do
something you were watching something
like the sword faith for instance I mean
it was up watching it last night for the
frost hang was just like fudge a duck
you know I kept going my god I can't
believe that he stammers well there's
only that you could only a Greek could
do this you know no other no other
camera operator could do what he did you
know so no it was a it was phenomenal to
be part of it and just I mean any actor
will tell you if you know David
sometimes doesn't like people saying cut
on set which sometimes you should let
let the scene play what's gonna happen
Oh are we finished don't even think that
this scenes finished because sometimes
that's when things will happen that you
just it will surprise you and so yeah
yeah I mean I think interestingly some
things you can't plan and something
shouldn't be planned more often than not
I find that in filmmaking the words
choreography and exposition of dirty
words however having said that what he's
so cleverly done you know in this by
accident or not who knows you know
allowing us the freedom of spontaneity
giving us the you know liberating the
actors to you know allowing them to make
mistakes and running with it and saying
we'll look you don't have a choice we've
got to carry on we've got to get to this
next bit and also it introduces the
incredibly complex political arena of
the time we talk about fealty to Lords
and to nobles to understand the backdrop
historically of what's actually
happening all in the space of eight
minutes which I don't think very many
films do you know as you know as
thoroughly and as as softly is that I
mean it's incredibly nuanced also it's
not too on-the-nose and we also get to
see all the characters that were about
to witness go through this sort of
brutal events over the next 137 minutes
one of the other things I really really
dug about the movie is just the it just
felt very authentic
there's gritty realism that you're
actually there though like the mud on
the ground looked like it must have been
a pain in the ass while shooting you
know but talk a little bit about just a
gritty realism and feeling like you're
actually there and you know
what you did to get ready I guess for
that sort of authentic take on the time
we there was a lot of horse riding
obviously and swinging swords and above
and beyond that I didn't really actually
have any idea on the day practically
what it would mean shooting so a
location could be you drive three hours
north and then drive an hour from the
hotel from base camp would be an hour
and pickup trucks or ATVs or whatever to
the location and then you get out of the
location put on 40 pounds of armor and
then this sadistic man would have you
run up and down the hill up and down the
hill with the armor you'd be in mud I
mean it every day was a new location it
was a different terrain that was
different weather the climate was
different
he'd be changing things on the spot it
was like I would say the physicality and
the exertion of it was so much that you
you didn't have much energy or time to
think about anything else other than
doing it which I think gives it if the
word is visceral or kinetic or there's a
pulse and an energy to it because you're
usually so fatigued and so tired you
need such a long day and the elements
were such that you didn't know if it was
gonna rain or you know or be hot or
muggier or have the the midges out or
whatever you just have to deal with it
in cope and I think that was a
tremendous boon for us that the the
elements of it were just as much a part
of our performances as it was for the
the visual you know MS onsen or whatever
sorry definitely gun to your bones the
weather didn't I mean and go through
that mud and beside Stirling Castle was
them you you know you were yeah you were
up to your knees in it basically I think
that's what Mackenzie intended for us
and delivered I mean he gave us
locations
and created those authentic environments
for us to to to be free and and play and
like you said that you never knew what
kind of terrain the weather the elements
it was all unpredictable so you're
stripped of any anything that like going
back to what Billy said you there's only
a certain amount you can prepare for as
an actor and then the rest of it you
really don't want to see what you've
been preparing on screen you want to
then just let go of any inhibitions and
you want to be able to allow it to to
hit you and and work off of that nature
to to work off of the I think that has a
beautiful bit actually that the elements
in the last final battle this begins to
rain and and Chris just looks up to the
sky like that's a blessing for us
because we know we they we know our
weather we know our land and that's
going to be our strength behind it and
so far you've seen the weather's change
throughout the seasons and it's so much
a part of a character or of the movie I
mean it's Scotland the landscape is just
absolutely stunning so but I have to ask
you the the final battle is this this no
I mean obviously the movie I don't do
spoilers but there's a huge final battle
in this movie what is it like to see
that on the page and know we have to
pull this off we you know what was it
like on the page how long did it take to
shoot and talk a little bit about just
trying to you know bring it to life
because it is fantastic on screen but I
would imagine it was so daunting to film
remember what it was like on the page
but it was definitely kind of you know
fairly basic it was based on the reality
yeah based on the reality of those
trenches which is from historical
research and we went to the real battle
so it you know and and looked around
that with historians so it was about
trying to make that come alive and then
of course you're dealing with the stunts
you're dealing with the horses you're
dealing with the mud we we built the
trenches so they were a bit more stable
than they would have been so the horse
could go up there not damage themselves
and all the spikes you see oh well I
don't want to say they were the
were added in post you know so that
there was no no safety issues but it was
it was it was everything we could
possibly throw into it to make it feel
real without risking you know life or
limb or animal real quick and again what
is it like knowing you're gonna film one
of these iconic battles in some huge
movie and you're going for that
authentic realism you know talk a little
about filming and you know mentally
going in and what it was really like
just for the first step I see that the
first time we shot this scene where
obviously Billy has a speech in front of
the English forces but the first time
that you know was Scottish British
Americans wherever we're from and Chris
Payne gets up with Robert the Britain
and starts their speech and there's a
bunch of guys and a bunch of supporting
artists around them you know where I was
and there there was pretty powerful I've
definitely felt like oh this was you
know gonna be a very sort of a
significant moment obviously it was in
history but definitely so standing up
there I think it was we had raindrops
didn't we yeah that was real
bloody rain was a slate libera Thunder
and it was ass of ominous and so of
romantically beautiful at the same time
you know and it was just there you got
almost like a sort of a throwback to
what it may have been lake and how these
men you know and families would have
felt bonnet to these battles that when
it was it was kind of a I don't know a
suicide mission in many ways it was that
game over you know you were gonna die
but um but no that was it was very
powerful to be part of that most
definitely yeah I think um yeah going
off the back of that this sort of rally
to war these sort of two two moments
Chris has a moment weighs rallying his
troops and it's quite succinct and and
you know beautifully put and I think
what it touches upon is why are we here
like we're all here facing our imminent
deaths potentially and I think the most
powerful thing in that is that everyone
is together they're fighting for a you
a unified cause and it sent shivers down
my spine yesterday you know hearing
Chris uttering those words on the screen
and seeing this mammoth you know event
that that's about to take place
but understanding fully I think I fully
understood it then seeing Chris say that
which is um why those men were there and
what they were fighting for and that
that you know to me on the day you know
doing doing the same thing it's so
interesting that Edwards take on it you
know who Edward ii you know it seems
more kind of pernicious and and and
spiteful and there's this sort of
desperation and and that's juxtaposed
with this this unity and this beautiful
sense of togetherness that the Scottish
troops had you know albeit 20 of them or
however many they were for me the most
important important part of the battle
scenes really are the cumulative effect
of them it's like a war of attrition
it's brutal and it's long and it's
bloody and it's not a pornographic
depiction of violence I think a huge
component of our film is human as human
and human as animal and there's a great
will to power amongst every species on
planet Earth
usually it doesn't come with the
encumbrance of stuff like the divinity
and religious kind of B'nai ting and the
the divine call to be a monarch and to
lead and all that but it's all melted in
mucky and I think it makes a lot of
sense the last scene as humans covered
in just mud it's almost like we're
coming up from the earth and that no
matter what one says you can fight as my
character says in the end you can fight
for everyone ultimately it's one animal
against another animal and one's gonna
die and one's gonna live so it's the
most primal of all primals it's like
you're gonna either die or live so you
better make a choice now whether or not
you want to do one of the other and I
think there's something
beautiful in the the primitiveness of
that element is that I think the
depiction of violence in this is that
this is not Braveheart there no
emotional heart strings being plucked
there's none none of that this is this
is just humanity at its most beautifully
base and it's it's there's no moralizing
about it it just is what it is and
there's an exhaustion at the end that I
think you feel there's no elation
there's just men that are bloody that
have lost people they lost their friends
and family
wives are gone his dad's dead does dad
hated them I mean it's all just it's a
lot of suckiness so I think that that
call to will do power
it's what Tony says to my character
Angus says this is the price you pay you
know this is not an as Billy says at the
beginning we played with wooden swords
well the wooden swords of childhood are
suddenly stripped away and it's metal
and lost limbs and you know Power has a
price but yet we all want it we've been
doing it for millennia so I think
there's some really deep themes that
visually depicted in that mud and grit
and sweat and grime show the you know
show just what kind of animals we are I
really sincerely want to say thank you
for coming into the studio
congratulations on the movie and I
really hope while everyone's gonna be
able to see it on Netflix November 12th
9th November 9th everyone I hope that it
can also some people can see it on movie
screens because it was phenomenally
projected last night it just looked so
great on that note but streaming on
Netflix
November 9th thank you so much Oh as
well so so there will be an opportunity
for theatres the theatres and I
obviously would love it people did you
know but you can watch it on both
platforms you know that's that's the
that's the future I was going to say you
know if you can see it in a theatre
definitely um thank you all so much for
real thank you
[Music]